які ваші очікування від цьогорічної
конференції від цього форуму е десь
збираються навіть більш впливові
політичні діячі і експертів я почну з
того що це перший форум який
відбувається за абсолютно інших обставин
він відбувається під час повномасштабної
війни тому що останні форми які
відбувався він був напередодні війни і
тому це абсолютно інші реальності і тому
сьогодні ми маємо говорити не про
перспективи превенції війни А про те як
зупинити цю війну про те як е-е зробити
все для того щоб Україна перемогла про
те як захистити цінності якими говорить
весь світ про те як зробити все щоб той
хто а-а нахабно розпочав цю війну він
зробив все а для того щоб ця війна
зупинила щоб Україна перемогла щоб
Україна отримала відповідні компенсації
щоб Україна а-а ствердила те що принципи
міжнародного права які лежать в основі
співпраці усіх націй народностей вони
були порушені на вибаганку однієї людини
безперечно Тобто ми виходимо з того що
нам потрібно декілька основних пунктів
перше питання - це звичайно більше зброї
більше сучасної зброї яка дасть
можливість швидше припинити цю війну у
нас немає часу тому що кожен день цієї
війни на превеликий жаль має свою
жахливу ціну і ця ціна це життя
українських воїнів які сьогодні боронять
весь цивілізований світ від агресії
Росії далі друге це питання санкційного
тиску тому що санкції ми я про це буду
говорити вони повинні перестати бути як
новий вихід iPhone Ми не повинні чекати
10-го 11-го 12-го в ці санкції повинні
бути один раз і назавжди Росія повинна
зрозуміти що вести війну їй економічно
нестерпно далі ми будемо говорити про те
що ми вимагаємо Справедливості у цій
війні це означає що всі хто почав цю
війну вони повинні а-а бути визнані
міжнародними інституціями винними у цій
війні вони повинні отримати кримінальні
вироки вони повинні отримати відповідні
приписи щодо фіксації війни грубо
говорячи Путін повинен отримати чек за
цю ганебну війну від усього
цивілізованого світу тому що за цю війну
повинен заплатити Путін і Росія а не
платники податків країн Європейського
Союзу Британії Канади Сполучених Штатів
це справедливо далі ми будемо говорити
про просування України Про просування
України в напрямку Європейського Союзу
ми зараз є кандидатом до Європейського
Союзу Але ми хочемо почати справді
реальне просування до НАТО і ми Очікуємо
на вільнівському саміті запрошення
України до НАТО і будемо його
обговорювати всі питання пов'язані з цим
Тобто великий комплекс питань Ми хочемо
обговорити але в основі цих питань
навіть більше чим Україна в основі цих
питань це правопорядок в світі
unintelligible буде просування Тобто
будуть конкретно зараз таки неформальне
тут обговорення тобто воно воно потім
виліється вже в конкретні рішення
безперечно тому що для того щоб рухатися
треба обговорити і саме тому ми зараз
знаходимося тут на мюнхенській
безпековій конференції для того щоб
обговорити наші напрямки обговорити те
як ми будемо рухатись а далі лідери які
представлені тут країн світу вони Я
думаю будуть імплементувати в тому числі
рекомендації Мюнхенської безпекової
конференції
підприємствами президента попереджав про
війну і так що змінилося те що Президент
не може приїхати тому що він знаходиться
у війні звільнилися те що сьогодні
будучи на відкритті цієї конференції я
отримав два повідомлення один про те що
в Україні повітря на тривога а друге про
те що Міністерство внутрішніх справ
попереджає про небезпеку і бути більш
акуратними в поводженні замінованими
територіями цього не було минулого року
цього року на жаль це реальність і я про
це говорив сьогодні на відкритті що
Ласкаво просимо така реальність в
Україні Ми не хочемо такої реальності Ми
хочемо щоб Україна знову як країна яка
завжди сповітує мир як країна яка є
засновником організації об'єдних націй
знову вернулися в мир але мир ми бачимо
виключно через перемогу України до
[музика]
української
країни і східні країни Я думаю що
сьогодні коли ми маємо річницю цієї
страшної війни вже весь світ зрозумів що
немає часу на розкачку треба діяти
інакше війна - це як вірус Вона може
поширюватися далі а вірус ковід і інші
Він не знає кордонів він знає тільки
мету мету нав'язати свій правопорядок
повернути весь світ з 12 сторіччя де все
вирішує сила сила а не право ми цього не
хочемо Ми хочемо щоб увесь світ і далі
був і існував на засадах міжнародного
права міжнародних принципів за які
сьогодні воює Україна в міжнародний
трибунал для Росії як іде цей процес
відбиток Ну ми зараз проводимо
перемовини з дуже багатьма країнами
багато країн підтримується він
обов'язково як частина включений у
формулу Миру президента Володимира
Зеленського ми напрацьовуємо це разом з
формулою Миру ми пропонуємо країнам
по-перше підтримати цю формулу миру в
цілому і по-друге взяти патронат над
якоюсь складовою з цією формули Миру
тому мені здається що спеціальний
трибунал матиме майбутнє тому що там
дуже важливі привітаційні факти повинні
бути визнані які будуть мати важливе
значення для подальших міжнародних
судових процесів тому мені здається що
це дуже важливо і винуватиме перспективи
тобто створення неформальних країнами чи
вже якісь є
вже є у нас е-е ціла низка країни які
підтримують це тобто ведеться створення
такої коаліції щодо створення
спеціального трибуналу і я думаю що
ближчим часом ми зможемо вже завершити
цю дискусію прийти до реальної справи до
створення міжнародного спеціального три
який законодавчі ініціативи готуються
для того щоб полегшити доступ зброї
захід
[музика]
ної зброї дивіться за парламентом ніколи
не було затримок ніколи парламент завжди
все що потрібно виконував першим і що
стосується Європейського Союзу і що
стосується нашого послугу до НАТО і що
стосується всього що потрібно для
закупок зброї митні е-е податкові ми
знімаємо всі речі тому що ми розуміємо
що це питання виживання України тому
будь-які законодавчі зміни які будуть
потребувати задля нашої Перемоги
парламент готовий прийняти щодо станції
проти Росії
[музика]
Як можна посилити санкції
саме важливе для будь-яких санкцій це
неможливість обійти їх будь-яка санкція
вона повинна бути однозначно якщо
санкція має шпаринки для обходження або
варіанти для того щоб обійти його через
якісь інші країни це це анесанкції це
якісь обмеження А ми розуміємо що
сьогодні ми не можемо говорити про якісь
про якусь
а лікування ці цієї війни через
гомеопатію Ми повинні говорити про
хірургію і ця хірургія повинна бути в
санкціях коли буде хірург такий як f-16
ми очікуємо І ми його готові для цього
хірурга дякую